on vous parlait il ya quelques jours de
révélations faites par le site
d'investigation bri zone des fuites de
documents qui nous apprenait les liens
entre le ministère des affaires
étrangères britannique et des groupes de
presse telles que reuters ou la bbc
formation de journalistes locaux appui à
des médias d'opposition et transmission
des valeurs britanniques à l'étranger
l'émission dévoilé dans l' enquête
s'inscrivent dans une volonté plus large
de je cite contre l influence de la
russie parmi les médias cités on trouve
aussi le site d'investigation
britannique belling 4,1 des documents
publiés dans l' enquête debré zone
évoque la mise en place d'un programme
mené par le ministère des affaires
étrangères britannique en macédoine du
nord en vue des élections de 2010 9 dans
le pays un scrutin perçu comme très
important car censé définir l'avenir du
pays
comme un candidat potentiel pour
intégrer l'otan tout dans le projet le
ministère des affaires étrangères et du
commonwealth a identifié la macédoine du
nord comme un pays prioritaire pendant
deux semaines notre équipe et des
partenaires du consortium incluant 10 fr
labeling cats ont fourni un entraînement
sur la cybersécurité en formant aux
enquêtes numérique l'investigation en
open source et sur la déontologie des
médias l'une est d' appuyer un médias
macédoniens alors qu'au même moment
béline 4 publié justement un article
condamnant l' ingérence russe dans le
pays
culotté surtout que l'indépendance de
belline cat est souvent remise en
question sur leur site ils présentent
les entités qui les soutiennent
financièrement
parmi celles-ci on trouve par exemple y
national endowment for democracy soit
littéralement la dotation nationale pour
la démocratie une fondation qui prétend
soutenir la liberté dans le monde entier
et qui se trouve être financée par la
maison blanche et le congrès américain
parmi les autres partenariats
revendiquée par béline 4 il y à l'open
in formation partnership un organisme
qui se présente comme un réseau dédié à
la lutte contre la désinformation et
quand on regarde 12
leur financement on tombe sur le
ministère des affaires étrangères
britannique
le bureau des affaires étrangères et du
commonwealth du gouvernement britannique
a fourni un financement pour le high
pays afin que nous puissions soutenir le
rôle crucial que la société civile peut
jouer pour s'attaquer à la
désinformation
alors elliott higgins le fondateur de
belline cats a beau tourner ces
accusations en dérision les liens
étroits entre le site d'investigation et
les autorités britanniques et
américaines ont de quoi interroger
d'ailleurs elliott higgins a travaillé
dans le passé au sein du département
numérique de l'atlantic council un think
tank américain très proche des positions
de l'otan les dernières révélations sur
les liens entre belling cat et la
diplomatie britannique s'inscrivent donc
dans un questionnement plus large autour
de l'indépendance de ce site
d'investigation des questions que nous
aurions aimé poser directement aux
journalistes de belinga malheureusement
nos demandes sont restées sans réponse
en tout cas les révélations du site
grisonnes ont mis les algorithmes de
twitter en alerte
le réseau social a fait apparaître un
signalement sur les messages qu'ils
partagent l enquête en question avant
finalement de le retirer le signalement
n'ayant fait que rendre l'article encore
plus viral